- He looks so weird now.
(techno music)
- I'm Samantha.
- I'm Julian.
- And this is my jokester
boyfriend, Julian.
- We've been together for
somewhere around, like
- Year and a half.
- A year and change.
- And we've been together for three years.
(techno music)
- So we're going muscular.
- Going muscular. Like, not
that he's not muscular already.
He definitely has, like
that arm definition.
- Yeah. I guess if you could
just age her a whole lot.
I'd like to see, like,
her wrinkly and such.
- Probably get a little
definition in those arms.
- OK, let's give her some biceps.
- Give him some, like, 90's boy band look.
Like, maybe some frosted tips.
What he actually looks like
is Fred from Scooby Doo.
- A slight fro would look like.
Do you know how, like,
90's era Will Smith?
- You need, like, a bigger butt.
- In fact, if that doesn't look like
a pink Nicki Minaj-type wig.
- Soul-less white, I guess.
- Raise his eyebrows to match
the excitement of his mouth.
- Yeah, let's just drastic tan.
- And is there any way just to
make, like, really big lips?
- Just gonna take over his face.
- Just even bigger.
- I really like when Safiya
has sort of, short hair.
- Yeah, if you could make
him duck more, please.
- Thank you, that was great.
- Thank you.
- I think she's gonna like it, we'll see.
(techno music)
- You gave me age, why?
- No, no. I made you old.
- My face is a little redder.
- I made you tanner.
Where did my hair go?
- Well I gave it a little bit of a cut.
- I kinda like it.
- (laughs)
I definitely have on a pink
wig instead of a grey hat.
- It really looks like
I have a bigger butt,
except that leg.
- [Marcel] You don't like that--
- I got a pin leg and a big butt.
- And I also love that, you know,
I got, like, the Fresh Prince
of Bel Air haircut going.
- Gave you that V.
- Oh, that V.
Oh look at that, I got a little cut going!
I look amazing.
I could look like this all the time.
- Now, obviously the elephant in the room
is that she gave me blonde hair, OK?
- Oh my god, you gave
me huge biceps, what?
- No, no, no, no.
I have an explanation for this one.
- You know, this makes me
look like a action hero.
- And look at your lip.
I gave you a big, juicy, sex lips.
- Oh, it's so sexy.
- Do you like it?
- Yes, I love it.
- Awesome.
- So she gave me, I don't
know if it's higher cheekbones
or a smaller, pointier mouth.
She's given me a beak-like feature.
- I feel like I put a little
more effort into yours.
- What?
- My point is that, like, you know,
if you get a little jacked,
you know, a little bit stronger,
a little bit more Michelle Rodriguez,
I'm still gonna love you, baby.